bonsoir je suis donc ingrid baeck art et
je suis ici parce que j'ai un parcours
de vie un petit peu particulier
voilà je suis pas chercheur pas
philosophe pas professeur simplement une
personne qui a dû faire face jusqu'à
faire avec souvenirs 1984 j'ai 12 ans et
une méchante engine sous les conseils
d'un généraliste maman n'a emmené chez
le cardiologue à la maison mon peu je
m'attends il à moitié fait maman m'a
promis que je pourrais finir tout à
l'heure après examen dr est aujourd'hui
professeur m'explique que mon coeur est
attaquée qu'il faut l'aider que pour
cela je vais devoir rester dormir à
l'hôpital je finirai pas mon peu ce soir
à la maison les consultations sont au
deuxième le service de cardiologie
pédiatrique au huitième nous sommes dans
l'ascenseur est là l'image se graver la
présence attentionné du dr est le regard
préoccuper de maman et moi qui réalise
que ma vie vient de basculer
mon coeur avait donc été attaqué les
dégâts étaient là un coeur trop gros qui
n'arrivait pas à battre correctement
du jour au lendemain j'étais devenu
cardiaque un mot qui n'allait pas du
tout avec mon tempérament
un mot qui n'allait pas du tout avec
collège amis sortie lycée soirée grosse
fête escapades et ses résultats j'ai
flirté avec mes limites
les mots malaise cardiaque aller mieux
avec mon tempérament
c'est un état extrêmement intéressant
que celui d'être dans sa limite physique
celui de vivre son instinct de survie
le monde se revêt d'une nouvelle
clairvoyance
c'est comme si d'un coup je savait qui
j'étais
il m'a donc été donné très tôt de
ressentir la fragilité de la vie et ce
faisant à quel point il est essentiel
pour moi d'être heureuse vite maintenant
mais maintenant c'est maintenant tout de
suite là profitez profiter même de ce
malaise de cet état qui devenait alors
intéressant à vivre trouver l'intérêt le
positif le rire le goût aimer aimer
l'instant quel qu'il soit y avait un
truc normalement bref aimé l'instant
quel qu'il soit pour cumuler et cultiver
une joie intérieure souvenirs 1991 j'ai
19 ans et un choeur devenue énorme en
deux mois de temps
mardi soir les soins intensifs les
alarmes sonnent beaucoup la femme du box
à côté était toute souriante le matin
elle est tombée dans le coma et on
s'apprête à la transféraient lever le
bras demande un effort que mon coeur ne
peut plus fournir
c'est la fin je suis à vous je le sais
je le sens dans mon box des médecins se
tassent autour de mon cardiologue
adorait qui m'annonce qu'il va falloir
changer de moteur je ne comprends pas
quand on ne peut pas savoir ingrid dès
qu'il y aura un coeur pour toi cette
nuit peut-être alors je comprends je
réalise que ma vie est en train de
basculer
onze jours après j'étais greffer je sors
de cette greffe totalement paumées à
tous niveaux
submergé par la reconnaissance je me
sens redevable
comment remercier pareil cadeau
comment remercier un inconnu qui n'est
plus et les médecins et ma famille et
mon cardiologue et ma femme mon frère ma
soeur
mes amis je dois tellement a tellement
ma vie doit être un merci je dois faire
honneur respecter la discipline du bon
gré fait
donc plus question pouce de pousser les
limites pour le coup et être heureuse
d'être en vie être quelqu'un de bien à
la hauteur
toujours souriante à force
le goût est parti il a laissé place à
l'angoissé était digne au lieu d'être
moi à force de vouloir être à force de
devoir être je ne pouvais plus être la
chute a été aussi brutale et douloureuse
que bénéfique c'était au printemps 2011
perdre le goût de la vie m'a aidé à
mieux le retrouver
en fait ça a été le point de départ d'un
d'un long cheminement au cours duquel
j'ai pu comprendre ce que c'est que
d'être soi et à quel point nous sommes
essentiel à nous mêmes
cette compréhension est passé par une
sorte de dépollution en cherchant les
pourquoi on se débarrasse de ce qui nous
embarrasse et le superflu part et tout
est plus facile
simplifier de fait le goût est revenu et
avec le goût l'envi cultiver sa propre
authenticité pour que pour que le monde
garde ses couleurs souvenirs 2001 j'ai
29 ans un boulot très sympa et depuis
peu un mari mon meilleur ami devenu mon
amoureux que je connais depuis l'âge de
16 ans lundi matin en fin de matinée
c'est une heure creuse au bureau très
bon moment pour appeler mon médecin et
lui annoncer la super nouvelle je suis
prête à être maman
et là le choc elle d'ordinaire 600 pas
et encourageant tu me lis sur un ton
fâché tous les arguments contre cette
aventure les médicaments anti rejet non
compatible avec une grossesse la
fragilité d'un corps qui a déjà bien
donné l'inconnue médical les
implications cardiaque et même mon
espérance de vie
il est probable que cet enfant est
encore faut-il qu'ils menacent en bonne
santé celui-là
donc il est probable que cet enfant
perdre sa maman très tôt dans sa vie
je pars pleurait dans la cage d'escalier
il avait toujours été évident en moi que
je j'allais avoir des enfants c'était
écrit et ça ne souffrait aucune question
aussi médicale soit elle
les arguments contre une grossesse mais
heurter sans m'atteindre je voyais même
dans certaines une nouvelle façon de
dire merci
quant à mon mari il suivait être greffés
ce pas une maladie et d'ailleurs je vais
très bien et il a raison résultat
accompagné de nouvelles équipes
on s'est plongé dans la voiture et et on
a réussi
ça a marché ça a été une belle réussite
avec des aléas bien sûr surtout
tellement de bonheur et puis ça va
marcher qu'une fois ça marchait trois
fois nous avons trois filles trois films
magnifiques et en pleine santé
les noms de ces merci et cette aventure
m'a enseigné l'humilité face à la nature
et surtout la confiance son avis oui la
nature est là et on peut choisir de la
pensée bienveillante
à partir de là la vie qui en découlent
et force a forcément quelque chose à
offrir
alors peu importe les événements il ya
du bon allez vivre qu'ils soient
évidents ou invisible c'est une intime
conviction osez la confiance en la vie
pour accepter non lieu pour accueillir
les aléas de la vie
souvenirs
2013 j'ai 41 ans est un cancer du sein
le gauche la période radiothérapie
touche à sa fin mon sens est totalement
brûlés j'ai mal je craque
mercredi début d'après midi figées dans
mon lit devant faire mes pansements
j'ai les yeux rivés sur le réveil les
antidouleurs devrait déjà faire est fait
j'attends l'accalmie l accalmie ne vient
pas en revanche ma fille oui ma grande
fille de 10 ans arrive et me demandent
enfin me propose son aide
je veux dire non réflexe je la regarde
elle est désemparée et là d'un coup je
dis oui oui oui j'ai mal
oui j'ai besoin de toi oui j'accepte on
aide
elle bondit revient toutes équipées
accompagné accompagné de ses deux
petites soeurs
et là je les vois me soigner toutes les
trois chacune à sa manière la douleur
laisse place à l'émotion
c'est l'un des plus beaux moments de ma
vie j'avais toujours gérer seuls mes
souffrances physiques adolescente
dès les premiers signes de malaise
j'allais me cacher et souvent enfermé
dans les toilettes je gérais la réaction
des autres m'avaient conforté dans cette
attitude ce que c'était souvent
maladroit parfois même blessants et puis
le côté de la maladie paraît plus petits
quand on vit pour soi tout seul voir je
pouvais même limite le contrôle et donc
c'était un fonctionnement instinctif
testé et approuvé
là j'ai eu l'opportunité d'être à d'être
confronté à ce fonctionnement est
d'avoir le choix d'en changer
et j'ai changé et ça a marché ensemble
nous retrouvions de la puissance face à
l'impuissance
ensemble nous étions dans la force du
partage cet épisode
m'a révélé que tout fonctionnement aussi
ancrée soit il pouvait être changée si
un instinctif dit une conduite
il est possible d'agir autrement et
autrement a aussi ses avantages
en l'occurrence c'est génial de savoir
cacher encaissés mais c'est aussi top de
savoir reconnaître et partager j'ai le
choix
nous sommes libres nous pouvons changer
à chaque instant résistons pas au
changement
il ya toujours moyen de s'adapter et
d'en tirer l'essence bénéfique aux et
aux échanges et ses données voilà être
libre de soi même pour je pense que
c'est la clé justement pour non plus
faire face mais faire avec souvenirs
mardi matin 30 juillet 2013
depuis deux mois mon mari a une
maîtresse cela m'est insupportable
au vu de son attitude particulièrement
désagréable hier soir j'ai durant la
nuit fouiller dans ses affaires
il s'est réveillé il s'est emporté je ne
respecte pas sa vie privée il ne peut
plus me faire confiance je ne les
respecte pas il n'en peut plus il en a
marre il nous quitte 8h30 il emmène les
enfants au centre aéré
il ne revient pas et là je réalise dans
cet appartement vide silencieux qu'il
m'a quitté pau mais encore une fois
perdu
mon mari m'a quitté son considération ni
morale physiquement affaibli j'avais
passé le mois de juin à l'hôpital dans
un sale état
psychologiquement déboussolés je me
sentais moins que rien je devais me
relever méfier aussi vive et cet abandon
alors je me suis réfugié dans des les
valeurs trois valeurs la confiance
l'authenticité et la bienveillance avec
elle les priorités sont devenues claires
les décisions faciles elles ont été les
fondements de notre part les fonds non
les fruits les fondements fondations de
notre nouveau foyer
aujourd'hui très sympa à vivre chez nous
et ont de fait on a très bien vécu la
récidive de son cancer
la laque tu sais le coeur et les poumons
mais ce bond garde le cap et un set très
douloureux épisode de ma vie à ancrer
donc en moi le sens des valeurs
le pouvoir et le bienfait de ses
qualités qui élève l'âme elles peuvent
demander
elles peuvent demander rigueur et
discipline
elle offre toujours une direction une
aide un réconfort
en tout cas ça nous de l'est de les
choisir et de les laisser nous guider
chez nous on a décrété un et 2015 année
de la générosité ça rime pas on s'en
fout et résultats bref il c'est à nous
de les choisir
et ouais choisir ses valeurs visé le bon
pour sont entourés et donner du sens
voilà quelques tranches de vie qui ont
été autant de graines de changement je
les ai reçus j'ai fait le choix de les
deux participé à la pousse ma chance
inouïe et d'être accompagné par une
famille extraordinaire des médecins
géniaux et des amis au top alors un tout
petit merci ne représente absolument pas
tout ce que j'éprouve je voudrais
l'entouraient dans les normes
mais voilà tout mon amour pour leur dire
merci
je veux cette fort et et pour conclure
on sent plus loin
comme si
merci mais j'ai pu conclure alors c'est
très intime aussi parce que y'a mon
donneur qui dit à moi donc voilà et pour
conclure je voudrais vous dire qu'à mon
sens le vrai pouvoir est intérieure dans
dans la façon qu'on a de vivre les
héliades la vie dans les graines que
nous captons et et notre façon de les
transformer à nous d'aller là où nous
voulons que notre monde aie un perso
j'ai choisi la paix et vous merci
bernard